everyone needs a little pick-me-up a pat
on the back or the old high-five
and here's a little dose of you can do
it energy from someone we love
a motto that i live by is don't take
no as no this isn't for you take no as
not right now
so i guess in other words take it as a
comma not a period
because if i had taken every no that i'd
ever gotten as a finite
decision then i probably wouldn't be
where i am today
hey drew it's your friend zoe long time
when i first discovered that stunts was
something that people got paid to do and
made a career out of i became
instantly obsessed my dad at the time
was working at an emergency clinic as a
doctor and a guy came in with a
concussion
and turned out to be a stunt man and my
dad who speaks volumes about who my
father is came home with the phone
number because he knew that i wanted to
be a stunt woman and i
immediately was like what do you talk
about i can't call that person just felt
so uncomfortable and gross and
my dad made a statement that i just it
stopped me in my tracks because it was
literally irrefutable you could make
that phone call today or you cannot and
if you don't make the phone call you'll
wake up tomorrow and it'll be a normal
wednesday and you'll be
the same zoe you are when you went to
sleep and your life will be the same
life you've got now and that's all great
um or you could make the phone call and
you might wake up tomorrow
get me emotional you might wake up
tomorrow
as dumb woman it stopped me in my tracks
in a way that i was like oh
well then i just need to make the phone
call because what's the risk you know
and uh that literally was the beginning
of
a career where i have been a stunt woman
and then an actor and since producer and
i'm now getting into directing and it's
all
because of that sense of don't say no to
something because
of fear i have a piece of dating advice
for you right now
stay curious we are all in such a rush
to get to the happy ending that we're
missing a lot of those
magical moments that connection the
communication that happens
in that early phase of dating that we
never get back
so if you stay curious and take your
time
you will never choose wrong a great
piece of advice i've received is from my
mom as most advice
usually is from mom's and it is to snap
out of it
and my mom um said that once uh sort of
as
she was kind of joking around just snap
out of it but i do think there's such
wisdom
in that because you can only wallow in
your troubles for so long and it's
necessary and important to acknowledge
if something is
wrong or something's making you feel bad
but at
in some situations you just have to snap
out of it and move on
because you have to prioritize and you
can't give equal weight
to all of your troubles sometimes you
just gotta snap out of it
get out in the sunshine well it took me
44 years
to understand that there is no map
for how we're supposed to live that each
of us is a pioneer
and by that i mean that i spent most of
my life asking other people
what i should do but then one day i woke
up and realized
each of our lives is an unprecedented
and unrepeatable
experiment nobody has lived the life
we've lived with the pain that we have
with the opportunities that we've had
with the people that we have with
potential that we have
and so we have to stop asking people for
directions to places they've never been
hey drew this is marissa with your
motivational minute so i was once told
that we will go looking for
evidence for the story that we tell
ourselves so if we tell ourselves that
we can't attract a good partner
we're going to keep attracting people
who aren't good for us and if we
identify
as people who aren't good with our money
we're going to keep behaving in ways
that confirm that belief and if we tell
ourselves that we don't look awesome in
our clothes
every time we're out in public and
someone looks at us we're going to think
that's what they think because we're all
designed to go looking for evidence that
backs up what we already believe
ourselves
so if we're all gonna run around and
tell ourselves these stories
we might as well make it a fairy tale
tell yourself the best story you can
think of
because while it might not be true right
now
your mindset could change your life now
that was inspiring